4-1 ganó Brasil a Guinea en partido
amistoso lo hizo jugando en la primera
mitad con uniforme negro la primera vez
en su historia como parte de una campaña
contra el racismo durante la semana el
presidente de la FIFA Ian infantino se
acercó a la concentración de la
selección en Barcelona Basta ya ya no
podemos tolerar más problemas de
discriminación de racismo en el fútbol
infantino Busca sacar adelante nuevas
medidas para frenar el racismo en el
fútbol vamos a crear un grupo
de jugadores en actividades
que se reúnen con FIFA Para proponer
medidas concretas este movimiento llega
luego del último episodio de racismo
sufrido por la Estrella brasileña
vinicios Junior en la liga española el
21 de mayo su equipo el real Madrid
visitó el estadio del Valencia donde
recibió numerosos insultos racistas el
jugador denunció estos actos
generalizados en el fútbol español
recibiendo apoyo a nivel mundial
incluido el propio presidente Lula
comenzar entrevistas me gustaría
comenzar esta rueda de prensa haciendo
un gesto de solidaridad con el jugador
brasileño vinicios Junior joven negro
que juega en el Real Madrid
el Cristo Redentor de Río también se
apagó en gesto de solidaridad con el
jugador actos que responden actitudes
demasiado lejanas a los valores reales
del deporte